[Music]
did you guys ever use tinder when you
were single excuse me
tinder tinder excuse me no i can't that
[ __ ] was that offensive
that [ __ ] that [ __ ] wasn't around early
enough you get gold if you get gold
tender you could go based off of outside
of your city oh yeah what's the one
where the chicks get to pick bumble
dude
i have a friend oh wait no i don't know
i think so so i have a friend who had
success with that because she was like
like super like oh [ __ ] it's over
and then she went to that and she like
saw a bunch of dudes and then she was
approving those cats and she's actually
getting married now wow
good for her that's nice but we all
thought she was a lost cause like might
as well [ __ ] kill yourself but but
it's it's beautiful to hear that she
actually made it was it a uh grinder
that's the
guy one gay one yeah okay i had a moment
i think in like 2012 or i don't remember
what year it is but around that time
frame was living at bangoria where uh i
eventually was single for like this
brief period of time
so i was like [ __ ] it i gotta try this
i didn't know it was like kind of still
a new thing i didn't want to hate on it
and i had met some people and knew some
people that through eharmony had like
gotten married so i was like uh i don't
really close mine let me try it and i'm
living with uh three homies three
roommates in this house i get i download
the app and then i just realize
that the second i download it my phone's
already immediately out of my hand my
roommates are sitting on the couch
they're swiping everything for me yeah
and they're just cracking up they're
having the best time in their life and
i'm starting to start sweating bullets
and stuff it's vicariously a lot of fun
right yeah and then i'll after that
literally the next day i was like all
right i'm done with uh tinder because oh
that's it you never went on a date or
anything no never
it just turned into a totally different
social experience that's true how'd you
mean nina nina she was on my own dance
team at uci so when i went back to
choreograph i met her there she was on
cadc holy crap didn't know that cool so
you got with an intern
you [ __ ] a student i can't listen to
you while you have that hat on that
dude what are you hiding under there it
looks like over the phone yeah
coyote just hit you with a [ __ ] axe
handle or something like that
there you like
wayne's world yeah what's funny is that
guy is the gangbang
hey you did too
how do you think it felt when i realized
he was joe mama
i was like no [ __ ] way
i like bart [ __ ] laughing at this guy
bart's [ __ ] one chick for like 12
years
i did bart's like [ __ ] look at this
idiot with a wool hat
use the gang bang
and joe just laughs
well
joe by the way been [ __ ] giving fans
a hell of a time
[Laughter]
anyway the whole tinder thing why was
that they were lonely
i was asking because this uk woman went
on a tinder date
and uh they were dating for like a few
weeks wasn't even that long
the dude started getting weird
she broke it off
and then what do you think he did he
stalked her okay
he killed her
as crazy ass dudes do you follow her
nick's so cynical huh typical nick huh
what happened your mind goes to really
dark places this guy broke into her
house and filled her shoes with
spaghetti
oh that's awesome he's like i'm gonna
get her he is weird she'll go out on a
[ __ ] dead put her food on her shoe
and go oh i can't go out of date
that'll make her get back with me
did he make this video that sounds like
tychus sabotage like he would do a
sabotage move like that is anybody else
suddenly curious about like putting your
[ __ ] foot into a shoe full of
spaghetti
it feels squishy yeah
and i wouldn't be surprised if you did
that for jk party yeah we did a lot of
[ __ ] spaghetti in your shoes you
probably did it already before i stepped
on nitro takis or some [ __ ]
feels like mud probably
i'm sure it does to give you a little
bit of detail he did a lot of weird [ __ ]
he got into her place
and this is after she broke it off
because he was getting really really
weird what did he how do you break it
she returned home i think he got he
stole a key or something
and then uh this girl got home she finds
her shoes filled with beans and
spaghetti the walls are damaged the
furniture the clothes all the electrical
appliances have the cords cut off and
she's like you have
four more chances
okay one more date
all right you had me
i appreciate you cutting all the
appliances off for me and why is this
spaghetti warning in my shoes and why
does a guy go to [ __ ] a dollar store
for all of his pranks you know like all
the items like that
i think he just took what was in her own
kitchen refracting if you cut off the
electrical cord of my appliances i'm
gonna kill you
i'm gonna murder you in front of your
family bro that's it does she not have a
father
she lives by herself
yeah but then like she should be like
daddy does a [ __ ] stalker and [ __ ]
dude he did a lot of weird [ __ ] it says
uh he pulled my shoes out of the
cloakroom port oh yeah poor beans he put
condiments all over the walls cooking
sauce all over her vacuum cleaner oh he
got spaghetti from her
trash all of her makeup put shower gel
into the
drawers palm tree shaped ice cubes
you know what this reminds me of hello
it's kind of creepy but it's also so
weak and innocent it's kind of like a
guy it's like gateway stalker gateway
stalker right like he's trying to be a
badass like i'll [ __ ] get you and
he's doing all of these harmless [ __ ]
things he's just doing inconveniences
and it's like dude you know what i'm
gonna do is i'm gonna go to your [ __ ]
sock drawer and took out all the left
socks like damn
dude this guy sucks this guy should be
in a mental institution yeah dude he put
shower gel in her her
her clothes drawers do you think john
wayne gates this generation is soft
this guy's [ __ ] he's like the
generation of silicones is soft here's
some pictures this is the dude
right here i'm holding ryan's over here
with my phone
[Laughter]
i just suddenly become dawson
is he a minotaur or something
minotaur
[ __ ]
you know exactly what that is on the
right the [ __ ] horseman oh that guy
centaur centaur
here's the here's the vacuum cleaner
with all the [ __ ] that would bother
the [ __ ] out all the ravioli all the
things he's doing here's the shoes with
the spaghetti
these are white shoes that'll bother
them look at all that
[ __ ] mess this guy's a [ __ ] mess
dude dude that's a piece of [ __ ] i guess
that's a pretty decent revenge
considering the personality type of his
[ __ ]
because like that would [ __ ] bother
me if you did this to my house i i dude
that's like i left the window open and
the [ __ ] stray cat came and [ __ ] my
house up that's how i feel like
that's what it seems like
i thought he said that happened to me
let me tell you guys
around his neighborhood have opposable
thumbs that can open up spaghetti you
know what extra [ __ ] with me if he got
the five dollar pasta sauce but then he
put in the shoes i'm like why the [ __ ]
did you do that dude you got the you got
the prego
the ragu yeah it said he's getting the
[ __ ] expensive one 550 you guys know
what i'm talking about that's what
pisses me off the most when it's all
like when you waste money on this [ __ ]
but let me tell you guys what what it
did when it started to get weird why she
broke it off because i think this is
where you can [ __ ] tell this is that
that type of guy oh it's her fault
no
it's absolutely not her fault but alicia
is the name of the girl
and she said we'd be watching a film and
then he just burst into tears for no
reason
i'd ask him what the problem was but he
just ignored me
then when we got together he would start
saying stuff like this is the stage of
the relationship when everything starts
going wrong oh god because he's
sabotaging a few weeks in yeah and then
uh she said we've only been seeing each
other for a matter of weeks super
confusing i don't understand why he's
being so intense and needy and then uh
she told him hey i think it's about time
we end it then he blocked her and that
was it the next morning
she goes to work comes home and her
place is [ __ ] what a [ __ ] dude
he's like you normally didn't ruin her
life spaghetti shoes first
first order of business you [ __ ] up my
vacuum cleaner dude oh man why do you
think i mean just before all of the you
know italian food and [ __ ] why do you
think guys get like that what the [ __ ]
is that [ __ ] yeah why is he crying at a
[ __ ] movie theater i mean movie just
for no reason like a good stage of a
relationship may just start self
sabotaging well you know we should ask
him how his relationship is with his
mother probably not good
dude you made it you made it too real
but it's probably true though it's kind
of crazy right
now i'm just thinking about ways
that's very good advice i missed my
sister's les out nick
that nick is never coming back hey that
thing is never coming that's nick at
night stop eating i'm never telling you
guys anything dude i don't tell you guys
anything that's nick at night yeah dude
i like that guy nick and knight that's
uh what does nick and knight entail
that's nick of loading me up baby you're
the you're the dude that goes hey sis
where's other sis get going get to it
baby why dares you gonna make out would
you make that and i do this i go i just
fall asleep like that i snap my own neck
in front of everybody
he's trying to get cpr that's why from
one of you boys and i pick steve i want
you to resuscitate no i don't know i
figured sister every time
he's pretending to [ __ ] go dead
because he wants cpr on some real [ __ ]
though that that's like a um
mental red flag oh it has nothing to do
with just like oh you're slightly weird
it's like no 100 of you is wrong in so
many ways so we should blast his photo
and full name for anybody else who needs
to be protected and saved from yeah this
fool should never get [ __ ] forever yeah
here he is his name is jordan kobold do
not date do not date the type of guy
stands like a foot away from you at the
supermarket and just looks at you
midline he just stands right behind you
like yo what the hell he like smells
your dad's hair
man
i make him eat like a lot of beans in
front of me and if he doesn't do it i'll
be like let's play a game called beans
and weenies if you don't finish this
bowl of beans i'll cut your dick off
that's a sick game dude and then joe
goes ask me if i ask me if i'm close to
my father
answer is no
the answer is no
[Music]
you